il est 10 heures ce matin et adada gars
dans le département de ouallam la
température atteint déjà les 43 degrés
ici la sécheresse a tout ravagé plus
aucun légume de pouce depuis cinq ans
comme vous va les aubergines les oignons
les tomates
salades les salades les pommes de terre
le shu fu et tout ça ont cultivé ici tu
as qu'on partait vendre sagna mais le
karaté do not
know puis sont inutiles on a creusé un
puits à la main il s'est asséchée lots
forage qu'on a près du village il s'est
asséchée lui aussi
sur les 25 puis que possède le village
seuls deux sont fonctionnels
ces femmes passent la journée à faire
l'aller retour entre le village et le
puits plusieurs d'entre elles commencent
avant l'aube puis là depuis qu'elle est
à 4 heures du matin vraiment
on espère que l'eau monte et ensuite on
puise un peu mais rapidement le niveau
redescend et on est obligé d'attendre à
peggy louer vraiment j'ai l'impression
que depuis dix ans la situation se
dégrade d'année en année
c'est la période la plus chaude au niger
d'avril à juin les ménages surtout les
plus ruraux sont soumis à des pénuries
pour tenir le coup des sécheresses
successives
plusieurs experts du climat préconise
une meilleure utilisation des ressources
en eau disponibles
nous pouvons les mettre à profit
aujourd'hui pour développer ce qu'on
appelle la culture de la petite
irrigation celle qui permet à chaque
individu de pouvoir accéder à un lopin
de terre - en quelques mois un pouvoir
faire de la culture pendant la saison
sèche n'est ce pas ce qui nous permet de
renforcer un peu n'est ce pas sa
sécurité alimentaire au niger la
sécheresse de 2021 la plus intense
depuis dix ans a fait chuter les
rendements agricoles de près de 40% par
rapport aux cinq dernières années